addition and subtraction addition and
subtraction what we learn tonight
integers we let that for instance you
know if I wanted to do other than five
take away one can to get full okay we
learned that we can think of that in
terms of integers as five plus a
particular other integer what would be
the integer that would make sense here
it'll be negative one wouldn't it right
right so in other words this subtraction
I should have written a bunch of four
lines this subtraction this addition are
really doing the same thing right
addition and subtraction are the same
operation just looked at from different
sides yes and it's the same thing with
multiplication division if you want to
divide something up or multiply right
that's the same country but going
backwards and forwards okay now that's
what I want to launch off for today this
idea of publication and how it relates
to fractions so dividing
a subheading that's the same as heading
because we finally got to the real idea
okay now let's remember let's build on
what we learnt about multiply fractions
before okay I think we didn't example
something like this if we went let's see
2 times 1/4 2 times 1/4 do you remember
what we did with this what's the answer
yep
anyone help net what do we do here
mark you have a go let me rephrase up
mom would you please have a go what's
that what's the talk about cork we hope
that you really so this two is actually
to River one isn't it
well done on keeping you tell me well we
don't pay for someone okay
now therefore what's why the numerators
that's above they're saying it's me
right and you're all set to multiply
your denominators
now we get to hear what can I do I can
have starts with the safe with the way
that simplify doesn't stop in a sea
really come on guys cancel cancel so you
can't told me the factor on to section
102 aha but here's what I what she did
notice two times a caught up to tons of
work
two times a corner right when I read it
here left inside right you put it all
together and you got this it's here
before right but we've looked at
fractions I'm really a kind of way of
writing division right so in other words
two over four rewrite this one more time
I can rise 2 / 4 2 / 4 + 2 / 4 are
literally the same thing that makes
sense yes now have a look at this line
with Nikki it's something very
fascinating yeah okay we led here right
the addition and subtraction can be
written as each other if you change the
sign of the number
okay 5 minus 1 is 5 plus negative 1 okay
now I can do the same thing with
multiplication and division you see this
but what's the difference it's not that
there's a minus sign in there isn't
there negative okay
what's the difference between these two
numbers hmm yeah jasmine okay so fashion
here and a whole number here but it's
not just any whole fraction and any no
bottom right yeah these these numbers
are related to each other this number a
quarter is this number upside down you
see that this is 4 4 is 4 over 1 right
so let me take this idea right and let's
generalize let's see how we can use this
in other ways okay if for example let's
write down another deeply okay
our dentists idea of right if I want to
multiply by any fraction like saved one
over six right so that's like two lots
of a six two months on the seat that's
the same as dividing but turning this
upside down okay turning it upside down
yeah
this tiny upside down business right
it's a very important idea we're going
to use it over and over again it's so
fun we're gonna give it a name okay
we're gonna call it this a 6 here and 6
right we're gonna call them reciprocals
reciprocals
so you can turn addition into
subtraction if you change the same okay
if you reverse the same but you can
serve multiplication into division if
you take the reciprocal if you turn it
up upside down if you swap the numerator
and the denominator okay that's how you
turn multiplication into division think
about another way let's let's put the
numbers to the other way around if I
take 15 divided by 3
like how many 3's can you fit in 15 and
of course the answer is fine right
but I can say this another way I can't
end this division into a multiplication
how would I do it I would use the
reciprocal right which is it's 1 over 3
so this is how many threes can I fit in
15 right whereas this is and which is 5
and this is what a third of 15 or what's
15 lots are the third which is still
these are all 5